the 3.3 kilometer long Friedrichstrasse
er used to be known for its numerous
pubs now it's a shoppers street but it
is also home to cabarets and theatres
big and small it all began with the
local railway station because it was
simply named after the street when the
station opened in 1882 it became so
well-known that Friedrichstrasse Sassoon
embodied the longing for life in the
capital we burdine begin a flutist rasa
money for theatre ralph hopper has
written a book on the history of
friedrich Strasse and the powerful
attraction it had especially for the
masses the pubs served mainly beer the
oldest building here was built by a
Bavarian brewery
cowboy hat I never can to show boy
commissioned a well-known architectural
partnership Kaiser and caused him to
build this beer palace here in 1887 and
88 had room for lots of people on the
ground floor and on the upper floor to
most of the buildings here were
destroyed during World War two during
the division of Germany
Friedrich strasse was associated with
the border crossings between East and
West Berlin one was checkpoint charlie
which was used by foreigners military
personnel and diplomats today the former
border crossing is a tourist magnet
there's also an exhibition on the Cold
War Friedrichstrasse a station also has
a museum which is in a former border
facility known as the palace of Tears
this is where people from West Berlin
could cross over to East Berlin and
where East German dissidents pass
through who the communist authorities
wants to get rid of by sending them to
the West
you've won 40 Vigo state they were given
the choice prison or exile to West
Germany and most of them chose to go to
West Germany but that meant they could
never return the tears shed here gave
the building its nickname
350 meters further on is the
Friedreich's stat Palast
a review theater named by the New York
Times as one of the 10 must-see spots in
Berlin
I'm who not theme every evening we have
a hundred and ten performers on this
stage
the biggest theater stage on earth you'd
have to travel all the way to Las Vegas
to find anything else like it in the
1920s Max Reinhardt monumental
productions alternated with music hall
performances in the building that used
to stand here in 1980 the structure was
found unsafe it was demolished and
replaced by the new
Friedrich Palast every year around
700,000 visitors come for the glitter
and the glamour many more people come to
shop in Friedreich's trousers equally
glamorous stores the dustman media
department store alone counts over 3
million customers annually they come for
the vast range of books and music
including what may be the world's
biggest classical selection a few blocks
south Gallerie Lafayette opened its
doors some 20 years ago as Friedrich
strausser's first real shopping
highlights after reunification Lafayette
was the first store that made people
with exclusive tastes realized they
could find what they want on Frieda
schnauzer is a unique selection of
products and individual brands that you
don't find anywhere else in Berlin
now in the run-up to the Christmas
holiday the shops on Friedrichstrasse er
are humming the lights and decorations
newer shoppers to the centers of Commons
you